لنفترض ان طهران ستجمد الاموال الموجهه
للمليشيات لعام واحدا فقط الايرانيون
سيكونون المستفيد الاكبر ما يقرب من 68
مليار دولار سنويا كما قلنا مبلغ سيؤدي
ضخه في الاقتصاد الايراني الى تحقيق
معدلات نمو لم تشهد البلاد بما يستجيب
لمطالب الشعب التي يرفعها في المظاهرات
البدايه من ازمه المياه وصفها وزير ايراني
بخطر يفوق ما تشكله اسرائيل والثورات
الداخليه 50 مليون ايراني يعاني من العطش
البحر سيتحول الى حل لا الى تهديد وذلك
ببناء محطات محطات تحليات لمياه لمياه
البحر محطه قادره على انتاج 530 الف متر
مكعب يوميا اي 20% من احتياجات محافظه
طهران والثمن لن يتجاوز 230 مليون دولار
اولويه اخرى قطاع الصحه المريض بوصف
المنظمه الصحه العالميه البلد بحاجه الى
عشرات المستشفيات الصغيره من فئه 100 سرير
رواتب الميليشيات تبلغ مليار ونصف المليار
دولار تكفي لبناء 200 مستشفى لكل
التجهيزات اللازمه البنيه التحتيه مشكله
اخرى
18000 ايراني يذهبون ضحيه حوادث المرور
سنويا طهران تبني الطرقات لكن الجوده
غائبه ولذلك هي تحتل المرتبه 77 عالميا في
جوده الطرقات اموال القواعد العسكريه التي
شيدت تحت الارض تقدر بمليارات وهو ما يكفي
لتحسين ترتيب البلد في عده مراكز التعليم
الجامعات مشكله اخرى تسعه ملايين ايراني
يعانون من الاميه بحسب البرلمان الايراني
البلد يحتاج لبناء الاف المدارس في
المناطق البعيده تكلفه صناعه صاروخ فاتح
4 ملايين دولار تكفي لبناء مدرستين
بمواصفات دوليه كل هذه المشاريع بجانب
تطويرها للقطاعات فهي ستساهم في حل مشكله
البطاله التي تبلغ
10% بحسب الارقام الرسميه